el ministro de salud de francia dio a
conocer las nuevas restricciones que
entraran a operar a partir del próximo
sábado en todo el país y para esto
mostró un nuevo mapa de todo el
territorio según la circulación de la
virus está está dividido en diferentes
zonas de alerta en la zona de alerta
reforzada están por ejemplo la mayoría
de las metrópolis entre ellas parís lyon
o burdeos allí a partir de este sábado
el aforo máximo será de mil personas
para eventos culturales o deportivos
tendrán que cerrar tanto los gimnasios
como salones de recepción y el salones
comunales estarán prohibidas las
reuniones de más de diez personas y a
partir del lunes dejando un tiempo de
concertación de 48 horas a las
autoridades y a los dueños de los
locales los varios tendrán que cerrar a
partir de las 10 de la noche además de
esta alerta está la una alerta un poco
más elevada es la alerta máxima allí
están tanto la isla de guadalupe como
marsella y ex en el sur del país allí
tanto bares y restaurantes tendrán que
cerrar sus puertas así como todos los
lugares que
público excepto los lugares o los
comercios de alimentación así como
museos cines y teatros pues esto se
cumple con un protocolo sanitario
bastante estricto en todo caso o libre
de aon dijo que todas estas medidas
entran a regir durante 15 días serán
reevaluadas cada semana esperando que
esto por fin funcione para mitigar el
número de contagios y por ahora pues el
gobierno nacional sigue eludiendo la
posibilidad de confinamientos ya sea
locales un confinamiento nacional